today we saw another senseless act of
gun violence killed at least four
Americans and injured at least eight
others this time in Louisville Kentucky
the president and the first lady are
praying for those killed and injured in
the tragic shooting in Louisville and
for the survivors who will carry the
trauma for the rest of their lives they
are grateful for the lmpd office
officers who quickly and courageously
stepped into the line of fire to save
others
once again today the president has
called on republicans in Congress to
work together with Democrats to take
action
to ban assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines to require safe storage of
firearms to require background checks
for all gun sales to eliminate gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
these are common sense actions we can we
can ask for and should be getting right
now
and it's what Americans want we know
that majority of the American people
support this instead we've watched
Republican official after Republican
official after Republican official
double down on dangerous bills
that make our schools that makes our
places places of worship that makes our
communities less safe
while too many Americans are paying with
their lives
so again we need to act and we need
Republicans to show some courage
republicans in Congress
over the weekend a single Court in Texas
has taken the dangerous steps of
rejecting fda's scientific approval of
mifa Preston a medication that has been
on the market for more than 20 years and
is used safely in more than 60 countries
providing Critical Care for Women
this court decision threatens access to
to this medication which is used not
only for abortion but also for other
critical person purposes like helping
women manage miscarriages
if the decision stands it will put
Women's Health at risk and undermine the
fda's ability to ensure patients have
access to safe and effective medications
when they need them the most
this decision further Stripes away
Americans fundamental freedoms and
interferes with a woman's ability to
make decisions about her own body
and it's another step towards the
ultimate goal that we've heard over and
over again from anti-choice officials
that both the state and at the both the
state and National level eliminating
access to abortion for all women in
every state
it is also an attack on fda's authority
to review and approve a wide range of
safe and effective medication for
Americans and could open the floodgates
for other medications to be targeted and
denied to people who need them
so we were prepared for this outcome and
as you all saw the Department of Justice
appeal the Court's decision and the
seeking a stay standing State spending
appeal but I want to be clear because
there is a lot of bad misinformation out
there me for Preston continues to be
available and approved for the time
being again me for Preston continues to
be approved and available for the time
being this Administration stands by the
FDA and is prepared to for this legal
fight and we will continue our work to
protect Reproductive Rights to ensure
that women can make their own decisions
about their own bodies without
government interfering with that I have
some more guests that are supposed to
come through that door any moment now
timing okay
[Music]
and so finally today
he was he was actually in the suit no
just kidding
I was here to join us to talk about to
give a preview of the president's uh
trip abroad where the president's going
to leave tomorrow morning for uh the
United Kingdom and also Northern Ireland
Ireland a trip that the president is
definitely looking forward to and with
that Admiral the floor is yours
thank you good afternoon everybody
so as uh Karine just mentioned president
is traveling to the United Kingdom and
Ireland this week and as I think you all
also know he's very excited for this
trip and has been now for quite some
time
tomorrow he will depart from Belfast
where he'll be greeted upon arrival at
the airport by prime minister sunac who
he also just saw last month in San Diego
at the August announcement on Wednesday
President Biden will meet with prime
minister sunak bilaterally from there
President Biden will head to Ulster
University to deliver remarks marking
the tremendous progress since the
signing of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement 25 years ago
and it will underscore the Readiness of
the United States to preserve those
gains and support Northern Ireland's
vast economic potential to the benefit
of all communities
today I think you all know is actually
the 20 is the 25th anniversary since the
Belfast Good Friday agreement was signed
ending Decades of violence and bringing
peace and stability to Northern Ireland
President Biden cares deeply about
Northern Ireland and has a long history
of supporting peace and prosperity there
as a U.S senator Joe Biden was an
advocate for how the United States could
play a constructive role supporting
peace
now following his speech at Ulster
University the president will travel to
Ireland on Wednesday afternoon he will
visit County louth where his great
grandfather James Finnegan was born and
the Finnegan family lived before they
crossed the sea to begin a new life in
America and they'll tour carlingford's
Castle on Wednesday night the president
will spend the night in Dublin on
Thursday
he will meet with President Higgins of
Ireland and participate in a tree
planting ceremony and ringing of the
peace Bell following that ceremony he
will meet again with the t-shuk Leo
varadkar whom the president just hosted
here for St Patrick's Day I think you
all remember in both meetings the
president will discuss our close
cooperation on the full range of shared
Global challenges he will then address a
joint session of Irish Parliament about
U.S Irish cooperation to advance
democracy peace security and prosperity
as well as this shared deep history
between the United States and Ireland
today one in 10 Americans claim Irish
ancestry and Irish Americans are proudly
represented in every facet of American
Life Ireland's a key economic partner of
the United States and the United States
and Ireland are working closely together
to make the global economy more fair
Ireland has been a key partner for 21st
century challenges as well and the Irish
government has been strong supporters of
Ukraine providing vital non-lethal
assistance including medical supplies
body armor and support for Ukraine's
electric grid as well as their
agriculture they have supported EU
sanctions on Russia and the people of
Ireland have generously welcomed nearly
80 000 ukrainians offering Refuge to
those who were forced to flee their
homes search of safety
on Thursday night President Biden will
attend a banquet dinner at Dublin castle
and on Friday the president will travel
to County Mayo where he will tour the
sanctuary of Our Lady of knock and visit
the north Mayo Heritage and genealogical
Center's family history Research Unit he
will then deliver remarks at St
Murdoch's cathedral which is great great
grandfather great great great
grandfather sorry Edward Blewett sold 27
000 bricks to in 1827 those bricks were
used to construct and support the great
Cathedral and help Edward afford to buy
tickets for himself and for his family
to sail to America decades later in
1851. president is very much looking
forward to that trip again and to
celebrating the Deep historic ties that
our two countries and our two people
continue to share with that and take
some questions
thanks uh Jonathan started on the uh the
classified document leaks um has the
president been briefed on this breach
and does the US government at this point
have any sense of who was behind him the
president has been briefed he was uh
first brief late last week uh when uh
when we all got word that there were
some documents out there uh and he has
been stayed uh briefed and in contact
with National Security officials
throughout the weekend so he has been
briefed and as for the source as you
know the Department of Defense has
referred this to the Department of
Justice for a criminal investigation and
I certainly would refer you to them but
I'm not aware that they've come to any
conclusions at this point about where
they're coming from and just to follow
up on that um at this point do you
believe the leak is contained are there
more documents out there that have not
been released publicly is this an
ongoing threat we don't know we truly
don't
moving to the tension between China and
Taiwan we know the president can pick up
the phone anytime and call President XI
we've been told this call is coming for
months why hasn't he just picked up the
phone and called President tree to say
knock it off the president looks forward
to having another conversation with
president and we'll do that at the
appropriate time and we'll certainly
keep you apprised at that it's important
that those lines of communication stay
open
the tensions are certainly high right
now we'd like to see this relationship
get on to a better footing and when it's
appropriate for the two leaders to talk
then that'll happen I want to stress
that said that we are and have been able
to maintain lines of communication
between our two countries even
throughout all these tensions and in
fact we're still working to get
secretary blinken back on a plane over
to Beijing as he was planning to do a
couple of months ago uh and we're in
talks with the PRC about potential
visits of secretary Yellen and secretary
raimondo at their invitation by the way
to talk about economic issues and while
it's not popular would the president
ever speak directly to president Assad I
mean would there be a conversation there
perhaps what is his take on this meeting
between house Speaker McCarthy and
president side not uncommon for uh
presidents of Taiwan to Transit the
United States as president Tsai did and
it's also not uncommon for uh Taiwan
officials certainly at the president
level to meet with members of Congress
as president said this is it's very
typical there's again no reason for any
overreaction here
still in Taiwan
um what what how does us see the latest
Chinese military exercises and is the
U.S confident that Taiwan and help from
the U.S could continue to deter China
from the military you know solution as
they would see it because what they've
been you know they're saber rallying the
quality was a lot more than Sabers and
it's more than rattling at this point
yeah so we're monitoring the exercises
as closely as uh I think you uh you
might imagine
um
they appear to be
a reaction to something that didn't need
to be reacted to in my previous answer
this is not uncommon for presidents of
Taiwan and this one in particular to
Transit the United States so there was
no reason to react in any way militarily
or otherwise they also reacted
rhetorically but we're very comfortable
and confident that we have in place in
the region sufficient resources and
capabilities to protect our national
security interests in the indo-pacific I
would add to your more specifically your
second question there's no reason
for tensions across the Taiwan Strait to
devolve into any kind of conflict
nothing's changed about our One China
policy nothing's changed about the fact
that we don't support Taiwan
Independence and nothing's changed about
the fact that we don't want to see the
status quo change unilaterally and
certainly not by force
but how did you react to his comments
about you know wanting to create a
superpower and so on do you do you wish
him luck is it just rhetoric or is it
kind of annoying to the to the US
Administration I'll let the uh I'll let
the LEC speak to president macron's
comments uh uh we are again comfortable
and confident uh in the terrific
bilateral relationship we have with
France and the relationship that the
president has with president macron and
the fact that we're working together on
so many different issues and the French
are stepping up in the indo-pacific I
mean they're conducting Naval operations
even as you and I are speaking right now
uh in the indo-pacific all in keeping
with a concerted effort by all of us
this vast Alliance or network of
alliances and Partnerships that we have
to continue to make sure that we're
standing up for stability security
prosperity and a free and open
indo-pacific
thank you Kareem in Kirby in light of
the classified documents I wonder if you
could tell us when was the last time
the
protocol to Grant security clearances
was updated or revised in the in the
government and in light of the leaks
does the president believe you should
take another look at that
I think the Department of Defense has
already started to take a look at
distribution for instance at the at the
Pentagon I'll let them speak to that I
don't know the answer to question on uh
protocols for who is or who is not
granted security clearances there is
already in place and remains in place a
very diligent deliberate effort to
manage security clearances and sometimes
we get knocked because it takes a little
too long for people's clearances to get
approved because the process is so
careful and deliberate I think
to your question I think we just need to
be careful right now
speculating or or guessing what might be
hind what might be behind or who might
be behind what looks like a potential
leak here of of classified information
so I we're gonna we need to let the
process sort of uh bear itself out
so there's a question
you're getting to remedies and I
understand that
we're only a couple of days into this we
need to let the Department of Justice do
their job investigate this see what they
learn now again
that said the Department of Defense has
already said
that they're taking a look at
distribution and and looking if if
there's uh there's changes they need to
make
um administratively there at the
Pentagon since it appears that uh they
are they have the locus of most of the
the documents
um but again before we start making
major muscle movements we really need to
know what we got here uh and have a
better sense from the justice department
just a couple of quick uh follow-ups do
you have a sense of the number of people
who would have had access to these
documents currently prepared for the
joints thousands I do not I'd refer you
to the defense department and then given
this leak and previous lease
America people think that that the
administration is losing the battle
against whoever wants to steal our
secrets whether it's foreign adversaries
or hackers or not I think the American
people need to know and deserve to know
that we're taking this very very
seriously the president the president
president the president has been briefed
on this he will stay briefed on this the
Department of Defense is looking into
this they are leading an interagency
effort here to review whatever National
Security implications uh uh might come
out of all this uh in the Department of
Justice is is leading a criminal
investigation so we're taking this very
very seriously there is uh
uh no uh excuse for these kinds of
documents to be in the public domain
they don't deserve to be they in the in
the public domain they deserve to be
protected so we're going to get to the
bottom of this
um and then if there's actions that need
to be taken uh as we learn more about
the extent of what happened here we'll
obviously take those
the president
Biden Bleak or is the White House
offering any kind of reassurance to
Ukrainian officials about the safety of
some of their most sensitive information
U.S officials have been in touch with uh
relevant allies and partners over the
last couple of days at very high levels
I'll leave it at that and can you speak
to not just the potential leak here but
what appears to be some doctoring of the
information is this something where it's
possible that there may have been a leak
but then a different actor came in
manipulated the information and posted
it online what's the working theory in
terms of the actual altering of this
information I don't know that we've
arrived at a working Theory it does
appear that at least in some cases
the information posted online had been
altered from what we think would be the
original source but there's just no way
I can tell you with any granularity
right now how that came to be uh we're
again we're diving into this as a
strenuously as we can to try to
understand that
um and keeping with your point I mean we
urge all of you to be very careful about
uh about how you report on this story uh
since we know at least in some cases
that information was was doctored thanks
two questions Sean uh first on uh on uh
China you said that was a reaction that
didn't need to be made some would call
it an overreaction but how confident are
you that there won't be further
overreaction leading to actual conflict
if if this reaction was an overreaction
well we certainly don't uh seek any
conflict and again there's no reason
Brian forth there to be any conflict
over this or confrontation quite frankly
since really this is all very status quo
nothing's changed not certainly not not
about our policies and it's not on
common for president of Taiwan to
Transit the United States
but to the exact question you asked
that's a question that needs to be asked
in Beijing about what next what we hope
is next is that again tensions
de-escalate and that we can continue to
communicate with the Chinese that we can
continue to work on getting secretary
blinken over there the whole purpose of
that trip was to restore some of those
additional lines of communication that
are still closed after speaker Pelosi's
visit the mill to Mill lines the climate
change lines that was what secretary
blinking was heading over there to do
and we'd like to see him get back on
that plane and head over to do that and
the second question on the classified
documents
um
has any of that leak led to a direct
compromise of efforts to support Ukraine
from this Administration and secondly
those in it who are in that business uh
say that the biggest problem we have is
that we need software and Hardware
upgrades to guarantee that we don't get
hacked is there any indication that the
government is going to invest in the
infrastructure to make sure that you can
block that in the future so on your
first question no we continue to support
Ukraine that's not going to change
president
I'm not going to talk about the specific
documents that are out there or speak to
intelligence I think you can understand
why I wouldn't do that your question was
has there been any effect on support to
Ukraine the answer is no we're going to
continue to support Ukraine as the
president has said for as long as it
takes on technological upgrades again I
don't have anything to speak to today
and I don't know that even if we did
that we would talk about that in a
public setting but again we're only a
few days into this we've got an
investigation going on at Justice we got
DOD looking at their processes over
there I think we need to let those two
agencies do their job do that work
when they were posted to when they sort
of gained attraction we're worried that
these documents are out there ma'am they
shouldn't be out there period That's the
big worry
um and then trying to figure out how
that happened and I'm sure as a part of
that the timeline will be looked at as
well but the main concern is that
they're out there period they don't need
to they shouldn't be absolutely
shouldn't be in the public domain
John has the U.S changed its timeline
for getting the necessary weapons to the
Ukraine military in any way I'm not
gonna I wouldn't even in the wake of
even before this story I would not sit
here and talk about specific timelines
of equipment deliveries you guys know
that what I I'll go back to what I said
to Brian we're going to continue to
support Ukraine that hasn't changed it's
not going to change
the second question separately on NATO
expansion now that Finland had is
officially a member of NATO what's the
timetable for Sweden being a part of the
defensive line we would like to see
Sweden join the alliance as soon as
possible but that is going to be a
discussion between Sweden and the
alliance and as you know there's still
some work being done in that regard but
we think they're ready now and we're
excited to have them as new members
John hi back here uh good afternoon I
don't know if you're familiar with this
but this is making a lot of headlines
today this story Walter Reed up the road
in Bethesda a leading Catholic bishop
says Walter Reed Medical Center is
violating the religious freedom of
service members who are at the facility
and they say that because Walter Reed
just ended his contract with the
Archdiocese for the military services
for providing pastoral care the
Archdiocese calls the move quote
incomprehensible are you familiar with
the story and can you stand
I'm afraid I'm not and even uh even even
if I was really this is a better
question for the Department of Defense
applications with the Pentagon over the
Taiwan issue the last several days I
don't I can't confirm that reporting
Steve I I don't know
the documents have you been contacting
anything the government's mentioned in
the documents to talk about it to try to
smooth things over as I said U.S
officials uh have over the last couple
of days certainly throughout the weekend
uh communicated with relevant Nations
relevant allies and partners as
appropriate at very high levels to
communicate with them about this bring
this up when he speaks to the British
prime minister later this week I won't
get ahead of uh specific items on the on
the agenda and that bilat but we'll
certainly be able to communicate with
you after the fact thanks John is the
president concerned about recent threats
of violence and Belfast and then more
broadly can you just walk us through the
decision to visit Northern Ireland at a
time in which their assembly isn't
functioning so on the on the recent
violence certainly we've seen uh that
over the last couple of days there have
been some and the president's grateful
for the work that Northern Ireland
security forces have done and continue
to do to protect uh all communities and
certainly the people uh in Northern
Ireland and he's again very much looking
forward to going uh to Belfast the
timing of this is really timed around
the 25th anniversary of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement in an agreement that
the uh that the president has a personal
connection to and obviously is a very
very proud to see has has uh has really
changed lives and livelihoods
um in Northern Ireland uh and again
that's really what's what's driving us
try again on President macron do you
have a response
again I'll let president macron speak to
his comments we're very comfortable and
confident in the strong Alliance and the
strong friendship that exists between
our two countries and the fact that we
have been working together on the
continent
excuse me and elsewhere around the world
with France whether it's I mentioned the
indo-pacific certainly on Ukraine in
Africa uh in the Sahel going after
terrorist threats there I mean there's a
lot of terrific bilateral cooperation
just alone between the United States and
France we're focused on that we're
focused on making sure that together
we're uh we're meeting the National
Security requirements of both our
peoples
uh you know
um these leaked documents show that the
US has pretty in-depth contemporaneous
information about Russia's military
operations inside of Ukraine uh have you
has there been any impact on U.S
intelligence gathering efforts in Russia
as a result of this league and then in
terms of the impact on allies who may be
concerned that the U.S simply can't keep
this kind of classified information
which is shared among allies safe
um what's what's the reassurance to them
I won't Jeremy I won't speak to
intelligence collection one way or
another on any given day about any other
uh around any topic so I'm just not
going to go there and as I said U.S
officials have been in touch with
relevant allies and partners given some
of these disclosures over the last few
days and will continue to have those
conversations as appropriate and then
quickly it's been nearly two weeks now
since seven was arrested in Russia why
has he not yet been officially deemed
wrongfully detained by the state
department state department has a
process that uh you know can take a
matter of days and sometimes weeks as
they work through that and I would refer
you to the state department to speak to
that in any event that said you already
heard secretary blinken say that in his
mind he's wrongfully detained
um so why is it taking so long again I'd
have to refer you to the state
department they've got a process here
that that they run through Jeremy to
make these determinations
um and we need to let that process uh
bear out
but setting aside for a second that he
hasn't been declared wrongfully detained
at least not as of yet
doesn't mean that we haven't condemned
his detention we have it doesn't mean
that we haven't been in touch with his
family we have it doesn't mean that we
aren't also uh working as strenuously as
we can with Russian officials to get him
released he doesn't belong there he
needs to be released he's a journalist
not a criminal and it doesn't mean that
we aren't going to continue to follow
those cases closely as we can we still
don't have Consular access and we're
we're also trying to get that too so
just just a quick follow I know you've
said a couple times that the
Administration has been in touch with
allies does that include specifically
South Korea and Israel given the
described sense of material as pertains
to those two allies we've been in touch
with allies and partners relevant allies
and partners I'll leave it at that okay
thanks John I understand that you're
saying some of these documents might
have been altered but is it your
assessment that at least some of them
are authentic
we know that some of them have been
doctored I won't speak to the validity
of all the documents uh the ones that uh
you know that that don't immediately
appear to be doctored we're still
working through the validity of all the
documents that we know are out there the
Department of Defense Department
Department defense has stood up uh and
it arranged the effort to try to look at
the National Security implications which
includes taking a look at these
documents to determine whether they're
actually valid or not and I'm just not
in a position to speak to that work
which is ongoing some are valid at this
point we're we're saying we we cannot
speak to the veracity and the validity
of any of those documents at this point
we're studying that where DOD is is
leading an effort to study that to
figure that out a couple more
thank you thanks Kirby I had a couple
questions about the Ireland trip I
didn't hear you mention a meeting with
King Charles in the president's schedule
is that not happening the president had
a terrific conversation with the King
last week to uh uh to talk about uh
certainly his upcoming trip here but
also to let the king know that the first
lady would be representing the
administration at the coronation it was
a terrific conversation and the King was
very grateful for it and the president
was grateful for the time that the king
afforded them these are two leaders that
have known each other a a long time and
have a very good relationship
it's about the president going there now
and then also I'm curious why he is
making the trip when he's making it
instead of going to the official
celebration which is around April 17th
and it's going to see President Clinton
and all those leaders there why is the
President Biden making a separate trip
from that he's already answered that one
I mean this is really time to closer to
the actual anniversary of the of the uh
Belfast Good Friday agreement and ask
for security concerns you know we don't
ever talk about uh security uh
requirements of protecting the president
but the president is more than
comfortable making this trip and he's
very excited to do it okay
just finishing up the cherry blossom
season in Washington and it's 111 years
since the prince tokunawa planted and it
was much of it was to present prevent a
war is there a role that Japan can be
playing especially China's next door and
some of these different crisis
his grandson just took over is there
some world that Japan could be playing
in some of helping the U.S with some of
these crisis especially in terms of
China I would argue that Japan already
is
um and has been for quite some time I
mean they just rewrote their National
Security strategy that gives them allows
them to be on a on a more assertive
footing in the indo-pacific in terms of
exporting security and Japan has been a
strong supporter of Ukraine they have
participated and will and we hope will
continue to participate in both
bilateral operations and exercises with
uh the Republic of Korea but also
trilateral with the United States South
Korea and Japan so they've been really
stepping up in a big way we're grateful
for that just follow-up
um for those of us that were embedded
during the wars Iraq and Afghanistan a
lot of this is really personal some of
our friends people we know are haven't
been able to come back what's is an
update on what's going to happen to all
those that trusted us and are left Left
Behind
I'm not sure I understand what what
some of those are still in Afghanistan
that assisted us
and Afghan allies there yeah they I'm
sorry I didn't understand the question
as I mentioned last week
there are Afghan allies still arriving
back here in the United States and able
to lead the country on a fairly routine
basis that that mission that work is not
stopped and it's going to continue yeah
I have one more on the document this
week uh specifically about uh the Allies
some of them have already said that they
were eagerly awaiting a sort of
assessment of what happened from the
United States is that something that the
US will do down the line when you guys
have more information as to brief those
allies who were involved in them we will
keep we will keep relevant allies and
partners as informed as we can
just a quick follow-up on Taiwan uh you
said that this was a reaction that
didn't need to happen is the U.S sort of
considering changing its posture in the
indo-pacific looking
to what happened over the past three
days over these uh military drills is
that changing in any way the US's
posture in the region no as a matter of
fact today there are naval exercises in
the Philippine Sea that the United
States Navy's conducting we're going to
continue to fly and sail and operate in
international waters and international
airspace as required to protect our
national security commitments again I'd
remind five of our seven treaty
alliances are in the indo-pacific region
we take those commitments very seriously
people or the person responsible for the
leaks of these classified information
and secondly have you been able gauge
what their motive is just based on how
they've released this information
the answer to both questions is no I
can't there's a Justice Department
investigation going on right now a
criminal investigation I'm certainly not
going to say anything that would
Prejudice that and that work is just
starting so we don't know who's behind
this we don't know what the motive is
and I think I can't remember who asked
before but we don't know what else might
be out there so we've got to let the
Department of Defense
run their process with the interagency
and taking a look at the National
Security implications of it and we got
to let the justice department be able to
pursue their investigation again
completely unfettered and let the facts
and the evidence take them where they
may and then we'll deal with it on the
on the back end
or anybody else who's considering
leaking information this is uh again
without confirming the validity of the
documents this is information that has
no business in the public domain it has
no business if you don't mind me saying
on the pages of uh of uh front pages of
newspapers or on television it is not
intended for public consumption and it
should not be out there
um
what we're going to try to do is do the
best we can to figure out how this
happened and again the justice
department will take it from a criminal
investigative procedure and if uh if the
defense department has to change
processes you know they'll do that but
uh
I I I I think every American can
understand at least I would hope every
American Academy
of this country
every day the way we do
one of the things we have to protect is
information not only the information
itself but the manner in which we glean
that information
uh and so I think you can understand why
everybody is taking this particular set
of disclosures very very seriously
the new Us in the UK started
negotiations on a trade deal nearly
three years ago what is the status of
those talks and do you expect that to be
on the table at all this week when the
president meets with the Prime Minister
we're not in active discussions with the
UK about a free trade agreement that
said even out at San Diego when the
president had a bilateral meeting with
prime minister sunac they they talked
about trade issues and they talked about
uh the you know trying to find ways to
to increase and to improve uh the
economic exchanges between the United
States and the UK and that kind of
discussion will continue but there's
there's no active discussions about an
FDA expect a news conference on this
trip I'm sure the Press War would be
interested in them
I I don't expect there'll be a news
conference on this trip yeah James thank
you very much Kareem thank you Adam well
a couple on the documents and then one
on Taiwan if I may
um I don't think that you would be
um uh telling us that this this
information has no business being
publicly shared uh if if you weren't
prepared to confirm the authenticity of
it if they were completely serious
documents I think you would say so and
you wouldn't be very concerned about it
I didn't say there were various
documents I said we're still determining
the validity of them they certainly
appear to be directly related to
National Security concerns and
intelligence that's that's pretty
obvious is there a gap between the
number of documents that have turned up
online
and the number of documents that you
know to have been compromised I'm not
going to get into a process James the
Department of Defense is taking a look
here at the National Security
implications of what has been out there
to date
um and they're they're doing the
forensics I'm not going to get into that
process
before we hit Taiwan um because you you
tell us that you simply don't know
what's coming next are you in is the is
the US government effectively in the
position of a of crouching and waiting
for the next bombshell to hit on
telegram or Twitter you're in a position
where you simply don't know how long
this is going to go on or how many
documents are going to be published we
don't we don't know what's out there
James
um we don't know uh who's responsible
for this and we don't know if uh
they have more that they intend to post
so we're watching this and monitoring it
as best we can but the truth and the
honest answer to your question is we
don't know and is that a matter of
concern to us You're darn right it is
uh in in different respects you have
been candid in saying uh what you are
able to discern about intentions of
other countries for example
um you you've told us that you discern
no uh immediate plans by by China to Aid
materially in the Russian war effort in
Ukraine you've told us that you discern
no immediate plan spot or movements by
President Putin to install tactical
nuclear weapons in Belarus along those
lines with respect to Taiwan right now
do you discern uh any movements by China
that would indicate an imminent plan to
launch military actions against Taiwan
that she has said he wants his military
ready by 2027. uh
but the but but saying you want to be
ready by a certain time doesn't mean
that you have an intent president XI uh
would have to speak to that specific
intent himself we're not seeing any
overt indications that that that kind of
movement militarily is either imminent
or inevitable
character
talking about Afghanistan when the U.S
was withdrawing one of the closest Ally
of the US was Pakistan and the president
did not call either the prime minister
of Pakistan at that time neither the
weapons that
many claim that around 6 billion weapons
were left neither they moved to Pakistan
to be moved out while Pakistan one of
the strongest allies which sacrificed
many lives was not taken on board and
why their services were not required
taking a word for what I'm not sure for
removing the U.S citizens for removing
the Afghans who were coming to the U.S
well I mean
we set up a vast network of what we call
lily pads to help get those evacuees to
safety
and we were grateful for many countries
assistance
and without that assistance we wouldn't
have been able to do it
as for Pakistan they
they I think it's important to remember
they also suffered from the threats and
still do from uh terrorist groups that
occupy that spine between the two
countries and we continue to talk to
Pakistan about those ongoing threats
about what they're facing
um but uh there was
um Pakistan was helpful in
in the in the withdrawal and when we had
to use well with their permission they
were they they allowed us to to uh to
move some helicopters uh over over to
Pakistan so that they could uh be out of
Harm's Way
so please uh uh former prime minister of
Pakistan Imran Khan has been shot before
the bullets and President Biden has had
kind relations with International
leaders for decades he's one of the U.S
politicians who has been known for
kindness among internationally
he did not call the Prime Minister and
now the country is in a lot of turmoil
as well if there's any chance the
president can bring at least all the
parties the military the Judiciary the
politicians on board so the country can
be stopped from further deterioration
and you know now look we firmly believe
in that for some time that uh uh that a
strong stable and secure Pakistan is
good for the region
um could you just clarify is the first
lady going on the Ireland trip
uh you know I don't I don't have the
actual traveling party here uh complete
for you
next time
thanks
John all right uh let's get going go
ahead see
the start of that Kentucky shooting
um in your statement at the top of the
briefing yeah you're critical of
Republicans but you didn't mention
anything with the president wants to do
it is doing himself without this is he
about at the end of his ability to do
anything when it comes to gun violence
in the U.S is he effectively a Bitcoin
powerless look Zeke as you know uh and
as as I've talked about the president
has talked about many times the
president in his uh first two years of
the Administration has done more history
has done more executive action than any
other president when it comes to gun
violence when it comes to stemming gun
violence when it comes to protecting our
communities our schools uh and uh and so
he's taken action he's taken action over
and over again just last month he was in
the West on the west coast announcing
another executive action and we are
seeing
um from these uh executive actions that
he signed more than a dozen that uh that
the Department of Justice has taken some
actions and pushing forward uh some of
the uh some of the kind of Provisions in
those actions especially as you look at
as you look at Red Flag laws and those
types of programs more than 300 million
million dollars went to about 49 states
and territories to put that into place
in those States so there is actions that
we have taken the thing is the president
cannot do it alone you know this this is
a there is a legislative process that
needs to happen and Congress needs to
act and I list it out to ban assault
weapons yes the president mentions that
over and over again in high capacity
magazines requires safe storage of
firearms require background checks for
all gun safeties eliminate gun
manufacturers immunity from liability
those are the things that need
legislative actions and so he cannot do
it alone and so we need Congress to act
and if you think about uh assault
assault weapons ban we know when we saw
when the president was involved in 1994
to get that done we saw we saw a gun
violence go down when it's Sunset 10
years later it went back up so we know
it could work and that's why you
continue to hear the president calling
on Congress to take action so you're not
announcing new actions now and is the
sense that the president's done
everything that he can look the
president is always going to find ways
so is his team uh so uh here that we
have the domestic policy Council we have
other offices here at the White House
you have the department of we're always
going to find and figure out ways that
we can take another step
outside of all of the historic steps
that this president has taken to
announce another way to protect
communities but the president has done
the work now we need Congress to act
about about the press conference on this
trip four-day uh trip to countries you
know why can't the president take
questions in the Press right now we just
don't have anything on the books for a
press conference at this moment the
president always loves to take your
questions shouted questions no but no uh
look when it comes to these types of
events as you know being the president
of of uh at one point of the association
there are these are relationships that
we have right with um uh with these
countries so when it comes to two plus
twos or anything like that clearly that
is not just on us that is also on the
country that we're visiting but as far
as a standalone press conference I just
don't have anything to share at this
time
increase Beyond seeking a stay how do
you plan to respond to the abortion
group so look um I don't want to get
ahead of the courts here as you know
that's something that we're very mindful
of the the Department of Justice were
quick to act as you know that as you
mentioned the stay and uh and we're
going to continue to move forward in
that fashion uh it probably is going to
go up to the Supreme Court which we feel
pretty confident that we're going to win
but we're going to be very clear here
and I talked about this at the beginning
the disinformation misinformation that's
out there me for Prestone is still very
much available still uh very much
available right now for women who need
it or providers who need it at this time
and so look this is a president an
Administration that's going to continue
to fight continue to fight the make sure
that women have the health care that
they need to make sure that they make
their own decision when it comes to to
their uh when it comes to their own body
and I also mentioned this too this is
what we're seeing currently right now is
part of it's part of the plan right it's
part of what we've been hearing from
extreme maggot Republicans in these
different State uh State houses and of
course of course National Republicans
saying that they want a National
Abortion ban this is part of this and so
uh they're they're going to continue to
take those actions I think we've seen
more than 300 pieces of legislation
coming out of state houses uh to take
away a woman's Freedom a woman's right
to make her own decision a decision that
should be between herself and her doctor
and so look the president's going to
continue to fight uh for uh for people's
freedoms and this particular women's
freedom and we saw we saw what what uh
what the American people said during the
midterms like they want us to continue
to do that continue to fight for their
freedom yeah so the administration is
going to comply with this Federal
judge's order look we are going to
always follow the law always but doesn't
mean that uh that we're not going to
fight doesn't mean that we're not going
to uh you know as you know doj has
continued to is uh appealed this and
will continue to fight in the courts and
so will the administration then move uh
to expedite re-approve of Memphis what I
look what I can say is that right now
doj has already stayed as as Steve
mentioned and is fighting is finding to
maintain the stay and ultimately win the
case as we believe in the Supreme Court
and so we're going to let doj do their
work the Department of Justice do their
work FDA re-approve this so what I can
say is that we stand by the fda's
approval of mifa Preston and we are
prepared for a long legal fight that's
what I can say from here that's what we
are committed to do to doing for the
providers who are making sure that this
is available to women and also for women
out there but again it's still available
and as we know this is a decision is
stayed for seven days from starting from
this past Friday and so the status quo
remains but again we are ready to fight
thank you
um AOC suggests that the administration
should just ignore the ruling and she
said that quote we know that the
executive branch has an enforcement
discretion is that true so this is
similar I think to what Terry was asking
me look we understand the frustration
right we get the frustration regarding
this decision absolutely uh and that's
why we were quick to act that's why you
saw doj take action uh we basically what
I said to Terry We Stand by fda's
approval of mifa presto and we are
prepared to have a legal a long legal
fight here that is our commitment to
women out there that is our commitment
to Americans across the country but I'll
say this you know it is danger it but as
a precedent uh as a dangerous precedent
is set for court to set aside the fda's
expert judgment regarding a drug safe
safety and efficiency it would also set
a dangerous precedent for this
Administration to disregard right a
binding decision so that's what I'm
getting to but again we are ready to
fight this is going to be a long fight
we understand this we stand by fda's
approval of me professional something
this is a pill that's been around for
more than 20 years I believe 22 years
it's since it's uh it is uh it's been
used in 60 countries uh so of course
this is something that we are we approve
and we stand by FDA to be clear for
people watching me at home who are
listening to Progressive saying you know
the administration actually has an
enforcement discretion and they could
ignore this you disagree with that so
what I'm saying is there is a process in
place for appealing uh this type of
decision and we will pursue that process
vigorously that's what the American
people can count on from the Biden
Harris Administration and do everything
that we can to Prevail in the courts
that's the commitment that we have
you mentioned that the decision whether
to hold a two by two here at the White
House is made by both
the administration as well as the
visiting party but is the decision
whether to have a press conference
abroad in Ireland the unilateral
or are the Irish
Irish no I think I was very clear I said
when it comes to a press conference a
stand-alone press conference which just
does not uh include the country we just
that is we just don't have a decision
well it's just not going to happen it's
not in the books to happen on this trip
decision alone right I mean if it's the
press conference that the president is
leading on his own yes it's a standalone
that's why I said a standalone press
conference that is not happening on this
trip
hearing a reason why you're not having
one then because it looks to not have
one here you're saying it's because it's
not just no I didn't say that I said
when it comes to a two plus two
regardless if we're away or regardless
if the country's coming here we do have
that is a discussion that we have with
the country right that is a a
conversation that's had and we do not do
that unilaterally so I was making a
comparison I was laying out that process
which I know every time a a head of
state visits or even if we go to another
country this question comes out of a two
plus two and so I was just laying out
the process as I've done many times at
this Podium I'm just saying at this time
we do not have a press conference a
standalone press conference for this
President I know I know that it is of
interest I'm just giving you the answer
on that good luck
um did the White House ask HHS secretary
Becerra to clarify his comments on
possibly ignoring the Texas order and
saying everything is on the table when
he was on the Sunday shows I believe
they put I believe they put out a
statement AJ says put out a statement
making making that clear that the
administration is not going to ignore a
ruling so I'm going to just point you to
the statement from HHS and then to be
clear you also mentioned I might expect
this could go
the Supreme Court are you suggesting
that the White House supports the
Department of Justice seeking an
emergency appeal with the Supreme Court
now while it is still trying to get it
blocked I'm just not I'm not suggesting
that I'm just saying ultimately we
believe we can win uh if this case in
the Supreme Court if necessary but this
is something that the Department of
Justice certainly is going to go through
their process what we're saying is we're
prepared for a long legal fight and
that's the promise that we can make to
women millions of women across the
country right now and can you share what
if anything vice president Harris is
doing on this issue today or in the
coming days given her work on abortion I
think you'll continue to hear from the
vice president on this issue this is an
issue that's very important to her she
has been very vocal on what's currently
happening on especially when you see
extreme Republicans taking continuing to
want to take away the rights of women
when they make this important decision
uh uh you know about their own body I've
mentioned the 300 plus pieces of
legislation in state that has come out
of state houses she's been very vocal
she's been steadfast on this and I'm
pretty sure you'll be hearing from her
uh in the near future
we're expecting the EPA
um how do you expect those to go beyond
some of the targets the president has
made for getting new electric vehicles
out and also just how does he balance
this this need of having tougher
Emissions on one hand while
you know the possibility that this will
raise costs for consumers so look I'm
certainly not going to get ahead of an
ongoing policy process I want to be
careful here uh but look when it comes
to climate crisis it requires ambitious
actions and the president has been
delivering on those ambitious actions as
you know when he walked into this
Administration he said climate change
was one of the four crises that he
believed his administration needed to
deal with so his investing in America
agenda has already sparked over a
hundred billion dollars in private
sector investment in elect in electric
vehicle charging and Manufacturing since
2020 the number of electric vehicle
models has doubled EV sales have tripled
and uh and the number of EV charging
posts is up 40 percent so uh look this
wouldn't be the first time that someone
has bet against this President as you
hear us say many times that you hear him
say about himself and it certainly won't
be the last time he'll continue to prove
them all wrong when it comes to lowering
cost for the American people this is as
you know something that the Press when
you look at his economic agenda when you
look at his Economic Policy lowering
costs for the American people something
that is at the at the you know at the
center of that is a priority for him and
he'll continue to certainly do that
as we sit here we just now have another
notice that there was another shooting
in Louisville with one injured and one
dead unrelated these two let me drill
down a little bit on what you've said I
know the Administration has taken action
the most that it can but has the action
this Administration has taken regarding
gun violence in this country included
speaking to members of the GOP and
fighting them up here to discuss the
issue with other legislative leaders
what exactly has because the as you well
know the president has a great a
reputation for making deals he did it
with the bipartisan
uh infrastructure deal so what has he
done specifically look Brian um first of
all as you know I have not seen those
reportings uh so I know uh um if that
certainly is the case certainly I want
to say our hearts go out to uh the
injured or uh and their families and so
again a devastating another devastating
day of shootings that we're seeing in
our communities and this is why we
continue to call on uh Congress Congress
republicans in Congress to take action
this is not okay our communities need to
be safer I'm going to get to your
question our communities need to be
safer our schools need to be safe
there's no reason that kids should be
going to school and teachers should be
teaching at schools and be worried about
their safety be worried about an active
shooter coming into their school there
should be no reason why places of
worship should be concerned about that
as they're praying as they're as they're
in their again place of worship and so
this is devastating this is devastating
to hear and we need to see some courage
I'm going to keep saying that but
because that's what we need to see from
republicans in Congress now to your
question there was a bipartisan piece of
legislation that was passed just this
this past summer on gun violence and it
was called the safer communities act as
you know and so that was something
because of this President because of
this Administration was able to bring
both sides together the other side in
particular to come up with this piece of
legislation that is now into law clearly
and it was the first major piece of
legislation on this issue that we had
seen in 30 years and so that is
something that the president was able to
do but as as grateful as he was to both
Democrats and Republicans for that piece
of legislation we need to do more and
he's going to continue to do the end to
your other part of your question look we
have our White House Offices here
including the ledge Affairs office who's
in continue who's continuing to have
conversations with members of Congress I
don't have anything to read out on
particular conversations on any issues
but there are tons of issues as you know
that we are always having conversations
about when it comes to Congress but look
we've taken action this is the president
has taken historic actions on this issue
he's not set back he's not put his feet
on the table and let the issue pass him
by he's taken action
but he has he has we were able to do a
bipartisan piece of legislation
look we have done the work there's been
like there's a bipartisan uh piece of
legislation that was signed into law by
this President this past summer and he
has done a historic amount of work even
recently just when he was the last time
he visited the west coast to deal with
this issue to deal with this very issue
I'm going to keep going
anytime you'd like to show up here in
this room I'm sure all of us can speak
for all of us saying we welcome here and
beer at any time I understand go ahead
therapist
some weeks ago President Biden said that
he would be going to East Palestine Ohio
at some point does the president still
feel the need to visit Ohio well the
president I mean once the president said
it so I will keep we keep that he keeps
to his word I don't have a trip to uh to
lay out or preview for you at this time
but I'm going to just let the
president's word stand
if he says the president said he's
expecting to at some time the president
means what he says I just don't have a
trip to preview at this time
uh thanks Karine I wanted to follow up
on electric vehicles
um you mentioned the investment some of
the companies investing in EV battery
plants here in the U.S are Chinese
companies is the administration doing
anything to stop China from cashing in
on green energy goals I don't have
anything to share on China's
specifically as it relates to electric
vehicles as you know the president is
committed to this you see that in his
inflation reduction act you see that in
the bipartisan
bipartisan
infrastructure law which which is very
very keyed in on making sure that his
gen his agenda and dealing with climate
crisis is dealt with so don't have
anything on China you know our our where
we stand on China we want uh competition
not conflict that's where we have always
moved with China you heard my colleague
speaks specifically on where that those
relation that relationship is just don't
have anything specifically on the
electric inductor field
companies coming in and building EV
plants again I just don't have anything
specific as it relates to China electric
vehicles good John thank you Karine uh
two questions two different issues uh
first of all on the abortion pill case
you said earlier in the briefing that
you believe that this particular case
will get to the U.S Supreme Court and
you also Express confidence that you win
at the U.S Supreme Court what gives you
that level of confidence because this is
let's not forget we're talking about
mifopresto which has been around for 20
plus years which is has uh has is also
around in 60 different countries and it
is something that FDA is allowed to
approve they have approved this and we
stand by the FDA when it comes when it
comes to this and I said if necessary
right we believe we will win we will win
this long fight if it goes to the
Supreme Court if necessary if that's
what indeed occurs because we are
committed we are committed to uh to the
this issue we are committed to making
sure that women have access to uh to uh
to uh to me for Prestone but also can
make their own decision when it comes uh
when it comes to their own body when it
comes to this type of of uh important
reproductive uh Healthcare decision that
women should have it is their freedom it
should be their freedom to have this
the second question has to do with the
lack of a press conference during the
president's upcoming trip and the lack
of press conference that we see in
general from this White House I
represent a news organization that owns
113 television stations and a question
that I'm often asked and I don't know
the answer to so I'll ask you that
question uh is the administration trying
to protect the president from our
questions uh please I answered
absolutely not absolutely not the lack
of any interaction in a formal setting
to have a press conference I mean the
president takes shouty questions I I
understand John I understand I
understand I've dealt with this question
about three times already I understand
it is it is it is uh the job of you all
to ask this question to me totally get
that and that's not a problem at all
um but certainly uh the president many
times has has Stan has stood in front of
all of you has taken questions on his
own because he wanted to see what was
all on your minds he wanted to see what
the questions you all were going to ask
him and he wanted to answer them
directly that has happened multiple
times many times during this
Administration and that will certainly
continue to be when it comes to a formal
press conference they don't have
anything to share it with you at this
time it's just one last thing yeah sure
but enough you recognize that as it
relates to Prior administrations the
president's predecessor uh President
Obama President George W bush I've been
here long enough to have covered
President Bill Clinton this is not the
norm the norm is we do get an
opportunity ask the questions to the
president about domestic and foreign
policy issues in a formal setting at
some point uh in you choose that point
but we haven't had that opportunity in
quite some time so I'll say this it is
also unprecedented that a president
takes as many shouted questions as this
president has and he has
[Music]
we'll certainly we'll certainly get the
data and share that with all of you I
hear John I hear your question I heard
Zeke's question I hear you I hear you on
the press conference on a formal Quest
press conference we get this probably
every couple of months when you guys ask
us about a formal press conference I
don't have anything to share with all of
you at this time uh and uh and I'll just
I'll just leave it there okay Jeremy
um a few moments ago you reiterated the
president's support for an assault
weapons ban but in his statement this
afternoon the president called for safe
storage of firearms Universal background
checks and eliminating
um uh liability protections for gun
manufacturers was that an intentional
omission of this all weapon then or is
that a shift in strategy not a shift in
strategy at all we were just being
mindful to the incoming information that
was currently coming in from Louisville
and so at the time we didn't know what
was exactly
um we didn't have all the information so
we just wanted to be mindful to that
specific uh to that specific event if
you will in Louisville but that our our
commitment and our calling out for uh
the band of assault weapons has not
changed and in that statement the
president lays out the pretty dire
consequences of inaction talking in
particular about Republican
um we hear from the president when these
shootings happen obviously
um but does the president feel that he
has made
full use of the bully pulpit to match
the dire consequences that he's warning
of I mean is there not more that he
could be doing to Lobby Republicans uh
to bring this issue to the fore every
day I would say this Jeremy anytime the
president uses the bully pulpit
uh he is talking directly to the
American people and I would say directly
to Congress as well this is a president
that has been committed to this issue
not just as president but as vice
president and also a senator I talked
about the 1994 uh the assault weapons
ban that he led on and what we saw the
data that came from there and what we
saw in those 10 years before it uh
before uh it uh it's at Sunset and so
I've said this many times before today
in this briefing room and I'll say it
again this is a president that has taken
historic actions when it comes to gun
violence and protecting communities and
really dealing with an issue that is an
epidemic an epidemic sadly when we saw
the shooting in Nashville he spoke on it
about three times on that issue and I
would I would easily argue when the
president speaks people listen and want
to hear what he has to say does he feel
he's doing the most he possibly again I
think when you've made historic taking
historic action on on this on an issue
from the bull from from the the
executive uh from the executive this
executive branch and trying to find
telling your telling your teams to do
everything that you can to figure out
what else can be done that is a
president that is active uh that is
taking action uh and uh and you know it
is a there's a legislative process to
this we need Congress to take action and
that's where we are
um Charlie I forgot about you Charlie
I'm so sorry yeah yeah really quickly
and then we have a guest so oh
what kind of guidance has the White
House been providing to States and to
Medical providers in the wake of this
ruling on Memphis Zone and and what is
your message generally to women around
the country to Medical providers who may
not be sure uh what the future of this
drug is and may have concerns look what
we have said taking your last question
first is what we have said is
Reproductive Rights is a fundamental
Freedom it is a fundamental right and it
is a medical decision that should be
made between a man a woman is pardon me
and her doctor without government
interference again without government
interference and so we've been clear
about that a vast of majority of
Americans agree with us we saw the
outcomes of the midterms but again
Republicans and officials I've said this
again over and over again in the state
house across the country have have
introduced more than 30 300 bills
restricting abortion so far this year
alone so what we have done is we're
coordinating with state leaders who are
fighting to protect Reproductive Rights
and we'll continue to do that as we're
going through this fight
okay Charlotte we have a Charlotte in
the room here from kids skid scope media
welcome Charlotte I know you have a
question for me
um first off thank you for hearing my
question
and um recently the number of children
with mental health issues is on the rise
um how is the White House position to
help specifically kids
so mental health issues affect so many
people including children as you just
laid out and kids Across the Nation and
the covid-19 pandemic sadly
disrupted routines and uh and
relationships and led to increases in
Social isolation anxiety and learning
challenges and so uh you know this is
something that the president and the
first lady certainly has led on this
issue and and we've they've done that
we've done that by making sure that
schools are have the ability to have
extra resources to hire social workers
to hire psychologists to hire what is
needed experts so that children in
schools in particular have an
opportunity to talk to someone and so
this is certainly has been when it comes
to National mental health this is a
strategy that the that this
Administration has taken very very
seriously and he believes that uh you
know
making sure that a kid's mental health
and they have the services that they
need is important and it's okay to ask
for help it is okay it doesn't it it is
not weakness to ask for help and so
that's why we put together this help
hotline call 988 and we are telling uh
you know we're telling people if you are
having a hard time and you need someone
to talk to call 988 you can call them
you can text them and there are experts
who are going to be there to help you
and so it is this is a uh and it's 24
hours seven days a week this is such a
critical question an important issue so
thank you so much for asking question
Charlotte
ice cream picking up on what Jeremy was
asking a couple questions one when did
the president find out about the
Louisville shooting
uh he found out uh this this afternoon
or this late late morning
civil before before after the Easter egg
rolls
uh I don't remember the exact timing but
he was certainly briefed on this uh by
his senior staff I can't tell you
exactly the timing because it's been a
wild day and has he reached out today to
Mitch McConnell or Rand Paul or any
other members of the Kentucky delegation
as you know this is a president that
regularly reaches out to leaders and
elected officials and in the state I
just don't have anything to read out to
you as far as any calls that have been
made but certainly the president was
briefed earlier today I just don't have
a specific time top I'm not aware
whether he's spoken to any other
Republican lawmakers
and he also raised the issue of
Republican congressing totally
understand the question I just don't
have anything to read out to you at this
time do you have an update on when the
president might visit Nashville where
another mass shooting recently occurred
well as you know the first lady went to
Nashville for the vigil and she clearly
represented the administration and
offered her condolences and support
from the administration to the community
and to the families that lost their
three kids and and three administrators
a very very sad horrific day and as you
know this is a president that has
visited many communities we think about
Uvalde and those 19 Kids and two adults
that were murdered you think about
Buffalo and at the grocery store when
everyday people just on a Saturday doing
things that many of us do on a Saturday
go shopping and they were gunned down
and he visited there with the first lady
and so don't have a don't have a trip to
to read out to you but again the first
lady was there
just day days after the shooting and
offered her condolences and prayed with
the family and supported the community
while she was there on behalf of the
administration thank you all right
everybody gosh I'll see you on the road
thank you everyone
thank you